Even though I walk through the valley of the shadow of death,
I will not fear for you are with me.
You are my light and my salvation.
You restore me and lead me for your glory.
I long to dwell in your house forever.
How am I supposed to follow that?
I was getting choked up, just standing there praying, listening to that.
Great. Are you Lord? Amen. That was sweet.
Thank you worship team. Well,
good morning everyone. My name is Ryan Whitaker,
and I love getting to serve as one of your elders. Thank you for that.
So I, I have to ask though, how has everybody summer been?
Been good, right? I see a lot of smiles out there and, hey,
don't worry students. I think we have infinite weeks left, right?
So don't worry about that for us. You know,
our summer has been pretty good. A few weeks ago,
Lindsay and I and our four kids, we, we all piled into our minivan. It's,
it's kind of like a clown car now, really. Uh,
but we piled into our car. We took a road trip to Michigan. Now,
if you're like me, uh,
Michigan really isn't the first place you think of to go on vacation to,
but we were fortunate to stay, uh, alongside a beach, a along Lake Superior.
And it was beautiful. It was, it was worth it. Now,
some of the beaches there in, uh,
in that area are blanketed by these round tumbled
rocks of every variety that you could possibly imagine.
Reds and greens and translucent and sparkly,
and those are just the ones that I know the geological terms for.
But what we learned from the locals is that for the good stuff,
if you're collecting for the good stuff, you have to dig deep.
The,
the really beautiful rocks are the ones that you have to dig
deep for and sift through. And so
pray that we're bringing up the rocks today in today's
psalm, that God wants us to see, the ones,
the rocks that glorify him the most. So while this,
this psalm today may strike you as familiar, the theme may be familiar to you.
I wanna challenge you to, to dig deep. Let's sit down and dig deep and,
and sift through God's word and pull up these beautiful rocks
together. So the,
the choice for you this morning is this.
You can hold onto these rocks as precious,
or you can find a,
a piece of driftwood in the approximate shape of a bat,
and absolutely
crush it right back into the lake.
At least that's what I saw my boys doing. So that's your choice.
This morning,
this Psalm touches on some pain that you might feel this morning,
some questions that you might have.
Is God angry with me?
Why is this suffering happening to me?
Is it because of something that I've done?
And will God rescue me? Well,
we believe that God's word is our anchoring truth.
So let's see what it says today. Before we dig in, let's pray.
Father, you are mighty to save.
Jesus, we need you. We can do nothing apart from you.
We can prepare and go and do in life,
but unless we do it with with you, it's empty
you and you alone bring the victory. Holy Spirit,
come in power. Help me to speak only what's in your holy word this morning.
And Christ's name we pray, amen. Amen. Now,
if you will turn in your bibles with me to Psalm 60. Psalm 60.
It's in the about in the middle of your Bible.
And while you're turning there, uh,
I'm so thankful for all the guys before me while John's on sabbatical.
We've had a lot of people filling in, all the guys filling in before me.
I'm so thankful for these faithful men. Brent, our boy,
Jimmy. He's always one of my favorites. Brandon, it was his birthday yesterday.
Make sure you tell him Happy birthday, but just wonderful,
wonderful gifts from the Lord in these men. I'm so thankful for them.
So, uh, I am in this lineup,
the pen ultimate as it were. Uh, next week we've saved the,
the best for last. We have Dr. Allen Rice and he's,
he'll be teaching us through Psalm 61.
And this will be before John returns the week after.
And we're so looking forward to that. So Psalm 60,
the heading for Psalm 60 says, says this,
he will tread down our foes to the choir master, according to sh sha Edith,
a mdo of David for instruction when he strove with Aram
Nahra and with Aram Zoba.
And when Joab on his return struck down 12,000 of Edam
in the Valley of Salt.
And so that's a, a long header.
It's a psalm that's meant to be sung to the tune of sh
Edith, which means Lilly of the testimony. Now,
we don't know what that tune sounds like,
but but since this is meant to be sung by a choir and it's during a time of
military pressure, it's likely to a driving marching beat.
Okay? So Psalm 60, it's written by David,
and he's serving as a, a voice for the people.
And it's a corporate lament.
God's people are crying out to him for help.
And this is a time when God's people were under military attack,
under military threat. And so,
so perhaps this is teaching us how to pray
during and through the fight.
Now, the,
the battle mentioned in this title is likely what we see in Second
Samuel eight, where David emerges Victoria.
So we know the outcome of this.
David's efforts come in as victorious,
where they defeat 18,000 Edomites in the valley of salt.
Now, that tally is a little bit different than what we see in this psalm,
but we can easily account for that by taking into account different generals
at play, Joe ab versus abs shy,
and also the timing of the tally.
So it's not an issue at this time.
David was probably ruling over, uh, only part of Israel.
Not yet all of it. And what's interesting about this psalm,
I think you'll find this interesting, is that this is like a behind the scenes
really, because it,
it exposes the defeats and the setbacks that David
and his people experienced when the military campaign wasn't yet complete.
And so in this way, Psalm 60 is like a peek into David's diary.
And second Samuel eight is almost like his Instagram,
his highlight reel as an example in Second Samuel eight.
You'll see this two different times.
But it says the Lord gave victory to David wherever he went.
The Lord gave victory to David wherever he went. And yes,
we know that to be true in an overall sense, overall victory.
But Psalm 60 gives us an inside view into the
turmoil and the defeat that forms the patchwork for it.
The Psalm is divided up into three distinct sections.
And I think it'd be more accurate to call it tectonic plate shifts.
Why?
Because we watch David as he goes from subdued
into deep dark defeat and depression,
perhaps to uplifted,
to mountaintop heights in verifiable victory.
And you only go from low defeat to high victory
when God is working in you in plate tectonic
shifting ways. So let's see that.
Let's dig in.
The first shift that we see is that David is rejected.
He is rejected.
Let's read verses one through four. Now, oh God,
you have rejected us, broken our defenses. You have been angry. Oh,
restore us. You have made the land to quake. You have torn it open repair,
its breaches for it. Toters,
you have made your people see hard things.
You have given us wine to drink that makes us stagger.
You have set up a banner for those who fear you,
that they may flee to it from the bow sayah.
Now these verses one through four, they immediately reminded me of, uh,
the song Trouble by Ray Lamont,
who here knows that song? I'm sure a lot of you do. Uh,
and I would sing it for you.
But my fear is that my rendition would be a little bit too accurate and
uh, it may cause YouTube to take this sermon video down. Okay?
So just the lyrics this morning, it goes a little bit something like this.
Again, this is trouble by Ray Laane. Trouble,
Trouble, trouble, trouble, trouble,
trouble been dogging me since the day I was born.
Worry, worry, worry, worry,
worry, worry.
Just won't seem to leave my mind alone.
So we have trouble and we have worry.
And this is, uh, exactly what we're seeing here in verses one through four.
And, and really it's, uh,
all of David's life is what what that is too. It's all trouble.
Early in his life, he was overlooked for King.
He contended with the threat of Goliath,
endless pursuit by Saul's murder squad. Thank you Brent for that word.
Exiled from his home for years, his wife McCall taken from him.
He lost Samuel, he lost his best friend Jonathan.
Even the loss of Saul was sorrowful for him.
His daughter was violated. His two sons,
Absalom, Ajah both rebelled against him. Both killed.
And then there's the whole episode with Bathsheba and Uriah and
on and on and on. It's good to be king,
right? When you're king,
you have king-sized problems
and the weight of a crown is measured in worries, not gold.
At least maybe that's how we're tempted to think here.
You know, when you, when you really examine the core of each of his troubles,
they're actually not that different than ours.
So see that this morning maybe you've had your string of troubles too.
You've been overlooked and o underestimated at work.
You've been passed over for a promotion.
Your boss is impossible or you're not given credit for something,
or you're even dealing with job loss right now,
or even hit with serious illness, financial hardship,
or even a family crisis.
Or you've sinned in some way and you're dealing with the consequences of that.
You've lost relationships, you've lost trust,
and you're dealing with personal guilt, immense personal guilt right now.
Or your marriage is struggling
or you feel alone.
And any of these troubles can make it feel as if
God is rejecting you. Well,
David is feeling that two.
So in verse one,
David starts with just that by stating how God has rejected him and his
people. Oh God, you have rejected us.
Have you noticed that? That when someone rejects us,
sometimes it can feel like physical pain.
Science seems to show that the part of our brain that processes
rejection is the same part of our brain that processes physical pain.
That's right.
They're saying that that rejection is like physical pain to
our brain. Now, I, I don't know if that's true,
maybe it is, but man alive, I do know that rejection hurts.
It feels like I've been rejected in,
in every sphere of life more than more times than I can count.
And I think that you've probably felt that rejection too.
So when David says God has rejected, rejected us, that hurts, David hurts.
And some commentaries here describe the scene of rejection as one that is
steeped in contempt,
that God is sick of him and that he is
so disgusted with him. He,
he's trying to fling him away as he would and insect, he's like, ah,
get away from me.
But I think what we're seeing here is David's exposed temptation to
feel as if God is rejecting him,
to feel like God is condemning him.
Continuing on in the text still in verse one, God, you've broken our defenses.
You've been angry with us. Restore us. He's crying out for reversal.
Here you have made the land quake, you have torn it open repair.
Its breaches for it. Totters.
This is like a building that's just about to fall over.
You have made your people see hard things.
You have given us wine to drink that makes us stagger. Now in scripture,
sometimes wine is a blessing
And sometimes it is judgment. Here it is judgment.
The wine here is judgment. It makes it to where we can't move.
It's bringing confusion and it's making us weak.
Have you ever said this before? Like I have,
this is so confusing why this is happening to me.
So now let's pull off on a scenic overlook. Let's,
let's put the car in park and uh, let's turn on the map lights and,
and figure out where we are. Let's ask some questions.
Do you wanna ask some hard questions this morning? Let's do it.
Why is David saying that God has rejected him, that God is angry with them,
that God has broken their defenses and on and on and on.
He's saying that God has done all these things. Why is he saying this?
Maybe the inverse question is this.
Why is he not saying that their enemies have done this,
that the enemy has broken their defenses, or that the,
the enemy has torn the land apart? Well,
it's because David is looking to the ultimate source here.
David says God has broken their defenses.
Yes, Edam, Felicia, Moab have all crushed David and defeat,
but they were acting as instruments of God's will
Agents or instruments of God's will.
So when David says, you have made us see hard things,
we rightly know that God has indeed made us see
hard things.
And we see this with Job when Satan takes everything away from
job, job says what He says,
the Lord gave and the Lord has taken away.
And what does this cause David to likely do?
Well if we know David from scripture,
we know that he is probably examining his heart
in the midst of trial. The trouble that's on him
is causing him to rightly measure himself and his people against
God's holiness.
In Psalm 1 39, 23 through 24,
David cries out to God and he says, search me. Oh God,
know my heart.
Try me and know my thoughts and see if there be any
grievous way in me
and lead me in the way everlasting.
That is spiritual self-examination.
And we'll see that this spiritual self-examination produces fruit.
And boy is that fruit. Sweet.
Let's talk a moment for on discipline and suffering.
Before we ask any questions. First we need to understand this believer,
God does not hate you. It does hate your sin.
And there is no condemnation for those who are in Christ
Jesus. Amen. Amen.
So how are you to understand the rejection of God's plans in your life or the
suffering that you're under? Is this discipline from the Lord?
Well, Hebrews 12,
six says the Lord disciplines the one he loves and chastises
every son he receives.
So God can see a pattern of sin in your life
and he may directly intervene to snap us out of it
and to refine us and to bring us into repentance. But understand this,
it's all out of his deep love for us.
So he can discipline.
But on the other hand, we look at passages like Matthew nine,
when Jesus is asked a question about why this certain man was born blind.
Well was it, was it because his, uh,
he sinned or was it because his parents sinned?
And Jesus answers?
It's not because he sinned or because his parents sinned,
but so that the works of God might be displayed in
him.
So God may or may not make it clear to you if
something you're going through is discipline.
But what we do know is that every trial, you're you,
you face is designed to sanctify you,
to make you holy and bring him glory.
In other words, he wants to kill your sin.
He wants to increase your joy in Christ.
He wants to increase your love for him and for other people.
And it's all under his banner of glory.
James one says this, count it all joy my brothers.
When you meet trials of various kinds for you know that the testing
of your faith produces what
steadfastness and let's steadfastness have its full
effect, that you may be perfect and complete,
lacking in nothing.
Back to the verse, back to the text. Verse four.
Here you have set up a banner for those who fear you,
that they may flee to it from the bow Sayah. When we read Sayah,
it's a good moment always to take a breath to pause.
And it says here that God has set up a banner for them.
The Hebrew word for banner is ness. What is a banner?
Well, a banner in scripture is typically a beautifully ornamented
flag or banner, and it's held up high on a po on a pole.
And it's held up front by someone brave,
perhaps the commander.
And a banner declares who you belong to and who you fight
under
a banner declares who you belong to and who you fight under.
Yet the context here, you have to see this is unusual.
The banner here isn't rallying the troops for an offensive,
but instead we find ourselves in a sea of trouble,
rejected shattered defenses, anger lo the the land torn apart.
Trouble, trouble, trouble,
trouble.
And this is signaling continued trouble,
not refuge or any sign of victory.
But maybe you could see it as maybe serving a defensive role as a place to
retreat and to hide. But maybe,
and I would say probably
this fleeing to the banner is disastrous as it paints a target
around God's people.
For the enemy archers to absolutely unleash their arrows.
That is devastating. Devastating.
So it's clear that God's people have experienced serious setbacks, serious pain,
and they have been rejected. Rejected. Okay,
so now let's move on to verses five through eight where we see our second shift.
This is a shift where David is reminded,
he's reminded of God's promises. Okay?
Again,
this is verses five through eight that your beloved ones may be delivered.
Give salvation by your right hand and answer us.
God has spoken in his holiness with exultation,
with rejoicing. I will divide up she him and portion out the veil of sko.
Gilead is mine. Manasas mind. Rai is my helmet. Judah is my scepter.
Moab is my wash basin. Upon Eden, I cast my shoe over Felicia,
a shout in triumph.
Verse five, that your beloved ones may be delivered here.
David makes the plea for deliverance or salvation for the beloved
ones. Now, in this plea,
you can feel his desperation and he's appealing to the intimate
covenant relationship between him and God's people here.
And David makes it personal by using the word beloved.
The that his name David means beloved,
we are your beloved. So save us.
Right?
And he asked God to give salvation by your right hand.
The right hand always symbolizes power. Save us by your power.
In desperation, he pleads to God, answer us.
And look here immediately after he says,
answer us. It's as if God is stepping in and says, here I am,
I'm speaking to you.
To be reminded of his promises is to revive your soul
and for your eyes to be enlightened. Psalm 19 says,
it's beautiful. 11 years ago,
I found myself in the middle of a challenging work situation.
I felt alone and overwhelmed. And it was,
it was hard to keep all the holes in the boat plugged
and this feeling of overwhelm flowed into all of life.
At this time, our four kids were still little bitty kiddos.
We were in the trenches
and it seemed like the Lord was leading me in a new direction. Now this,
this time wasn't a time of moral failing.
This was more of an more an issue of calling.
But what began was rug pull.
After rug pull and days turned into weeks, weeks turned into months.
Expectations were set only to be dashed and delayed.
And disapp disappointment after disappointment. It was a vicious,
vicious rollercoaster. God, have you rejected me?
Why have you not gone out into battle with me?
Is this discipline that you're bringing on me? God,
will you rescue me from this?
Can I be honest with you here?
It was in this season that I came to know what depression was.
Every morning I'd wake up and I would feel glued to my bed.
I didn't want to get outta bed.
But then I did get ready and I'd climb into the car
and boy, I'd gripped that steering wheel so tightly.
And as I'm driving into work, I'm looking through the windshield.
It didn't mi it didn't matter if it was hin, brilliance outside
every day was overcast.
But in that, in that struggle,
do you know what broke through the clouds for me being
reminded of God's promises, being reminded of God's promises,
I was reminded of his promises by meditating on his
word. Many passages were special to me,
but one in particular became so special to me.
Over the course of that year,
I can't tell you how many times I recited and prayed and even sang
this verse, Psalm 86, 5 through seven,
for, for you oh Lord, are good and forgiving,
abounding in steadfast love to all who call upon you, give ear,
oh Lord, to my prayer, listen to my plea for grace.
In the day of my trouble, I call on you.
For you answer me, He answers us.
And where did those verses come from?
They came from scripture memory,
man alive. I praise God for my friend Merle,
and for the near decade that I spent with him memorizing hours and hours
and hours of scripture praying for each other, holding each other accountable.
But listen to this, every time my heart and my mind were,
were tempted to believe lies from the devil about God,
lies about me, lies about my family.
God's word stood on the ready to immediately remind me
that he is good.
Even when it,
it sure seems like this isn't good to remind me that
he loves me even when it seems like how in the world can this
be love to remind me that he will rescue me
even when this pain feels never ending.
Now the standard asterisks apply here. Of course,
if you're struggling with depression, please get help.
See a counselor go to m oj across the parking lot, doctor,
come talk with one of us. We can help point you the right direction.
Whatever God leads you toward,
make sure that God's word is at the forefront of it.
God's word needs to lead. His word needs to lead.
Also, scripture memory isn't a replacement for regular Bible intake,
but give it a shot. Try it fighter verses.com Okay?
At the end, uh, all of this,
this sounds like a disclaimer for a pharmaceutical drug. Uh, uh,
scripture memory can cause discoloration of your Bible. Um,
but God's word revived my soul. It enlightened my eyes.
It broke through the clouds. Now the, the clouds, they kept coming,
but they kept breaking and eventually for good praise God.
Back to the text. Verse five, God has spoken in his holiness Again.
This is God showing up with his word after David cries for help.
Now look at these lands that God speaks about here, check him,
which is to the west of the Jordan, the valley of sakat to the east,
and so on and so on and so on.
Every one of these places is a part of the land that is, uh,
part of what God promised to Israel.
And if you were to connect each of these like dots on a map,
it forms everything that is under Israel's, under God's control.
This is Israel. It's kind of like if we were to say something like,
New York City is mine and Miami is mine, and San Diego is mine,
and Seattle is mine. And that would,
you'd come to understand that that is everything within the United States the
same kind of thing here. So as God speaks here,
he describes things as done, which haven't even happened yet.
And so we see in is in, uh, Isaiah 46 11. God says,
I have spoken and I will bring it to pass.
I have purposed and I will do it.
This is like a divine version of our phrase. Consider it done.
It's done guaranteed.
Except have you ever noticed how how confident some people are when they say
that phrase, consider it done wives, you ask your husband,
Hey, would you mind picking up some milk on your way home? And then you're,
you're hit with, oh, oh yeah, consider it done.
It's like he's giving you a five star guarantee that uh,
that it's happening right then and there. You might be tempted to think, boy,
he must be on his way to Brahms right now.
But then you get home and where's the milk? It's, it's nowhere.
It's nowhere. Consider it done. It's more like,
well, I contemplated it and uh,
if I remember to do it and if,
if I don't need to pick up some spackle from Lowe's, right,
consider it done.
How do we as people have the audacity to claim something is done that
isn't done? No,
only when God says something like, consider it done,
can we actually consider it done? It's not a maybe.
No. When God says it, the milk's already in the fridge. Okay,
back to the text.
These lands are divided up to each of the tribes of Israel. And when God says,
Gilead is mine, Judah's my scepter and so on,
he's affirming his sovereignty over every inch of Israel.
F aim, the protective helmet represents the northern tribes.
And Judah,
the royal scepter signifies the monarchy Jerusalem there in the south.
But guess what? God's sovereignty doesn't stop there. He says,
Moab is my wash basin. Eat him. I cast my shoe. Felicia,
I shout in triumph. Moab is east of Israel.
It's outside of Israel in a low spot near the Dead Sea.
And God is making it a place where he's washing his feet
and he's kicking off his shoes toward Edam also in the east.
Like he's like, they're a servant to him.
And he's shouting over Felicia in triumph, in victory.
So here when we see that God is in control of nations that have long been
thorns in Israel's side,
and these nations were once arrogant enemies,
but now they're serving in the lowliest of ways to the victorious
God of Israel. God opposes the proud,
but gives grace to humble. At this point we've seen David's plans rejected.
We've seen him be reminded of God's promises and now we'll see
David restored.
Let's read that now verses nine through 12.
Who will bring me to the fortified city? Who will lead me to Eden?
Have you not rejected us? Oh God, you do not. Go forth. Oh God,
with our armies who grant us help against the fae. For Sal,
vain is the salvation of man with God.
We shall do valiantly.
It is he who will tread down our FAEs.
Now this fortified city that we see in verse nine,
it's probably Petra, which means rock.
And this was a stronghold of edem.
And the only way into Petra is through the narrow and steep
canyon called the Sikh s I Q.
And there's only room there for two horses side by side to make it in.
And in this canyon, you were literally between a rock and a hard place.
Petra was a hard place to get into,
which also then means that it was a easy place to defend
The Tite.
Archers and troops would literally line the canyon walls and rain
down arrows and rocks on anybody who was to attack.
So suffice it to say Petra was safe for centuries.
So this is why we see David crying out
to God for help in this area. He says,
who will bring me to Petra? Who will bring me to this fortified city? Verse 10,
David reminds God of his problem. He needs help. Have you rejected us?
You're not going out with our armies. Verse 11,
David cries out in desperation. Grant us help against the fae.
Israel has no hope apart from God.
Starting now in the second half of verse 11 through the rest of the psalm,
this is where we strike gold.
This is the fruit of self-examination,
which is brought on by adversity.
The next three lines are the message that I believe that God has for us today
from Psalm 60. First,
David declares vain is the salvation of man.
Vain is the salvation of man.
And I think that this reveals the sin that David has uncovered
in the face of suffering. He has examined his heart.
And what is he uncovered? Pride.
His prideful. Striving is vain.
It's empty.
He tried to win the battle himself and he is losing.
Next verse 12, with God, we shall do valiantly,
valiant as in with courage and with determination.
Notice that this isn't saying Let's sit back in our recliner and let's
watch God do valiantly. No,
it's with God. We will do valiantly.
Our hand is on the plow and God's hand is on our
hand. Maybe you've heard this said this way.
God works in what? What we work out. God works in what we work out.
In Philippians two,
Paul writes to the church to work out your salvation with fear and trembling.
For it is God who works in you to will and to work for his
good pleasure. So we work it out.
God works in us to make it all happen.
Second half of verse 12 says this, it is God,
he who will bring down our foes. Make no mistake,
God is the 100% victor in the fight.
Proverbs 2131 says,
the horse is made ready for the day of battle,
but victory belongs to the Lord.
Victory belongs to the Lord.
This is no contradiction to the line before that says
this With God,
we will do valiantly
because he does it all and we give it our all. He does it all.
We give it our all. So in fact,
any efforts on our own try to do it without him is sin. Let's be clear on that.
And in this arrangement, the triumph isn't ours to claim,
but it's God's to give.
The Psalm is clear on this point. Without God we have no hope.
There is no backup plan, there's no plan B.
And this psalm in much of the Old Testament concerns itself with physical
battles and conquest. You see that,
but you and I know today that we are engaged in
spiritual battles. Ephesians six is very clear on this.
We don't fight against flesh and blood,
but we have a spiritual battlefield that lays in front of us
day in and day out.
And we are hopeless in these battles unless we have his presence, his wisdom,
his hand on our hand. And when we do,
we will do valiantly.
So in these shifts from rejected to reminded to restored,
it's clear, the same God that staggers us, steadies us.
Where the song trouble falls apart
Is that Ray LaMonte declares that in the troubles that he's in,
he's been saved by a woman.
Makes for a popular song, but a woman can't save you.
And women, a man can't save you.
So if you're here today with trouble surrounding you, you're feeling broken,
defeated, or lost, I want to encourage you.
I want you to know that you're in the right place.
This is a safe place to be real, to be vulnerable with God and with each other.
And we're not here to pretend like we have it all together.
By God's grace we'll be a people humble and lowly.
We're here to embrace our brokenness and to invite God's restoration into
our lives. You know, as we've studied all of Psalm 60 today,
maybe you're still thinking, uh, this battle that I'm in,
this doesn't feel like love. Guess what? When you read scripture,
you always read scripture in light of the rest of scripture.
So maybe this will help you.
Maybe Zephaniah a three will help you fill in some blanks.
Zephaniah is a prophet describing the coming day of the Lord,
which is a day of salvation through judgment.
This is f and i three 11 through 12. This is God speaking. Oh, on that day,
you shall not be put to shame because of the deeds by which you have rebelled
against me.
For then I will remove from your midst your proudly exalted ones,
and you shall no longer be haughty or arrogant in my holy
mountain. But I will leave in your midst of people humble and lowly.
So just as David and his pride try to muscle it and manufacture it,
and his plans were crushed.
So the Lord removes the proudly exalted ones like Edem,
leaving behind a people,
a remnant humble and lowly people who
desperately depend on the Lord.
So now listen to the joy, the restoration,
and the love that the Lord brings to his people. In verse 11,
this is glorious. The Lord your God is in your midst,
a mighty one who will save.
He will rejoice over you with gladness,
he will quiet you by his love.
He will exalt or rejoice over you with loud singing
believer He will deliver you.
He is the mighty one who will save. Consider it done.
God loves you, rejoices over you with loud singing,
and I hope that you feel that in your bones.
In Exodus 11,
Moses builds an altar to remember a victory that the Lord very clearly gave him.
And after that he,
he builds an altar to remember this victory that God gave.
And he calls this alter Jehovah NCI
Jehovah N,
which means the Lord is my banner,
the Lord is my banner.
The
This is very different than the banner that we saw today in verse four.
When we strive without God,
we are under a banner that serves as a target for the enemy.
Yet when we battle with the Lord well with God,
we will do valiantly.
And this banner that we fight under becomes the one that unites us and
assures us the victory.
What banner would you rather fight under
a target
Or
Under the sure sign of victory?
The truth is this.
There are people here today who aren't fighting under God's
banner. Maybe that's you.
You're fighting and you're striving and you're trying.
And I think that you're finding that it's coming up short for you.
But listen, there's hope. There's hope.
It's only through the gospel that we see Jesus Christ become our true
banner with him. Our victory is guaranteed
by burying our sins on the cross, rising from the dead.
He defeated sin and death. You see,
he drank the cup of judgment that we deserved.
He drank the wine that that was meant for us to cause us to
stagger. When we turn away from our sins,
trust in Jesus as our Lord and Savior were forever
identified under his victorious banner
and we fight with him valiantly. So today,
if you're not fighting under Christ's banner, come talk to us.
One of us down front after the service, we'd love to talk with you. Church,
Jesus is our banner.